get ready this is a very important game
the points really really matter all
right is everybody ready for the
questions
hi I am ready Marshall shoot when you're
clearly ready to go
the first quote in my heart I'm still
little I could have heard that a Yale
over 20 okay that is a 9 year old named
Samantha did we don't we all said over
20 whoa whoa you're treating me like I'm
a child you know there's an obvious
answer that's right
under 10 under 10 you're treating me
like I'm a child under 10 the answer is
21 year-old Cora
Miriam [ __ ] that that is a trick
question that was trig leap up all right
who did anyone happen who had it the
doctor of course the doctor had it okay
next question next one quote sometimes I
like to listen to Taylor Swift in my
room and cry about cats that have died
fame that's gotta be is definitely from
tumblr over 28-year old god no I'm just
kidding it's is it way which is it it's
an eight year older it's old it's an
eight year old Bickley I don't trust
your ass Emily got it okay one for Emily
to four-bit lay the doctor's lady okay
next quote mom dad you need to help me
no come on
yeah over 20 over Tibet 'ok okay so we
all go to that one next one
all right resist adulthood I realize
being human but some days I really wish
could just be a fairy this is always I'm
gonna say under 10 I don't think is a
woman or a girl named Emily at 4 years
old
hey alright alright so none for Emily we
got really impressing the next one is
quote can I wear a bear costume at your
wedding as I'm the ring bearer I am a
werewolf I'm alright you go on right
back at it
I feel like this is a trick this is 28
year old other candidate named Riviera
so who got that one ain't good though I
got it you don't know you don't
recognize other kin when you hear it so
in other kin for did you say over 22
yeah okay I have to put that so please
other kin is a one of the 56 genders
that now exists according to Facebook
and probably every university in the
country and other kin is it's like a
trans species but not a real species
like a fake species so like I think I'm
like a werewolf I think I'm gonna hell
yeah there was that
well that's there that's a different
thing I think there were also furries it
gets very very yeah we'll get into that
later
I'm sorry keep going Marshall okay next
one is I am made of gold treat me like
it I'm gonna go on your ten yeah go
millennia alright the answer is that is
a 20-something woman's sign at the
woman's March rally in Washington DC
I'm sorry you tonight I like that line I
had it who tell myself that in the
mirror every morning I would have a
poster of that on the wall
I am gold alright the next one is quote
it's about creating a home here that
isn't gimme but it's really sad than
it's a gimme
is Geralyn right that is Geralyn lugar a
Yale undergraduate Michael's old best
friend then yeah that's that is my old
my old professor Geralyn but they're
coming at you quote Donald Trump is a
bad man
what do you say that for he just is
Donald Trump is a bad man what do you
say of where he just is given that
logical progression I'm gonna say over
20 I'm gonna this is Kylie six years old
but I lost my lead
ally got it let's see whose know ok so
right now the doctor doctor Bickley and
Ally are tied oh alright let's break
that tie with the next quote I don't
vote I don't do voting YES under 10 this
is famous rapper and Coachella headliner
Kendrick Lamar over 20 right oh sorry
quadric Donald Trump hates brown people
I'll say over 20 right I could see some
Sun like college person saying that
whoever votes in a yeah that's your
final answer okay sure this is Chelsea
Handler 42 years old
LSP and ler ally the only one not
together
we all knew I didn't know his handler
though okay so Chelsea all right next
one close one
I know Trump hates brown people that's
the same quote I know Trump had people
with brown skin
that's still the same is that it is a
different quote this is a different
quote this is trying five years old it's
hard yeah I guess we had Bickley was
picking up on her system I would have
missed it
yeah what a sort I'd all right quote if
Donald Trump becomes president I'm gonna
be super super mad and I'll move to a
different world
I don't know actually getting nervous
about this now I yeah it could have been
like any celebrity I guess overt we all
say over 20 okay this is it Blake five
years old it's really sad that we can't
differentiate it this is really sad none
of us guys the last quote okay all right
so by the way so right now Ali and the
doctor are tied this is the type
possibly quote if he would it be elected
I'm moving to Jupiter also also
basically the same quote I'm gonna go
under ten couple this is Sharon age 1410
just share let's sure who got it oh you
both all right let's get out so Emily
and I lost there's a tie between the
good doctor Bickley and Ally but you
know what none of that matters because
there are no winners and losers here at
the Michael Knowles show there were only
participation trophies thank you all for
participating I feel like we're all
number one don't you feel like we're
just all I'm supposed to be number one
I'm supposed to be I'm supposed to be
this is not about an intellectual space
it's about creating a home here that's
what that's gonna be the motto of my
show okay